well we got some big news to talk about
we've got an update on the pandemic pink
hair trend that
you all want to know about last year we
saw remember light pink
and now the cut reports the pink is
getting pinker
this spring the pinks are coming in
hotter and brighter check out uh naomi
osaka's pink look
and then taraji p henson look at shakira
yes yes check out maluma baby yeah
that works right jermaine fowler but i
want to know
would you ever do the pink hair you know
ross i've tried every hair color under
the sun
i understand more about hair than i ever
thought i could or would
the one hanging chad of hair i would
like to try
is the pink trend oh you must it's you
have to live your um gem in the hologram
fantasy life you know and try it
i i couldn't pull it off i don't think
well maybe we'll get wigs and just take
a like a
a a run at it uh okay next juice news
oh well actually no well no there we are
that's a really bold look with the
blouse
and the hair and uh i feel like
you know what though i feel like i look
like i'm in a cool girl group
you certainly look like the bass player
yeah which is a total compliment
oh god
well told ya told you i couldn't pull it
off
actually i disagree ross i think you
look great and thank you
art department that's great news team
for like helping us see the light and
actually get to try it without damaging
our hair
all right next ross i want to talk to
you about this i want to talk to you
about
cork pardoned that's right cork okay
okay i just learned so much new stuff
about cork
and honestly i've gone cuckoo for cork
are you ready all right we know it as
the little plug that keeps your wine
tasty but allure reports that court
could be a secret weapon
in greening the beauty industry and this
is important because i am a beauty
uh maker myself and i'm always concerned
about the plastic and the recyclable and
the pcr and 2018 alone
7.9 billion with a b
units of plastic were created for beauty
products as well as personal care
okay it's a very large category that was
just in the u.s
but more companies are turning to cork
packaging because
cork is biodegradable it's harvested
from live
cork oak trees with no harm done to the
tree
it's like it regenerates itself and the
best news is harvesting cork
makes these trees actually regenerate
themselves which is done through
photosynthesis say that with a list
photosynthesis which removes carbon
dioxide from
the air wow i mean is that not the best
quirking news that you've ever corking
heard
uh listen the best part about this well
there's two things one
now whenever i open a bottle of wine i'm
gonna call it recycling right
and two really that it regenerates
itself is a game changer because they
can just take the bark
off the tree and that's where they get
the cork you know and then it takes it
like nine years to grow that back but
the tree isn't harmed
and they don't emit carbon into the
atmosphere
it's unbelievable and i think it's a
game changer i mean as somebody who's in
business is this something you're going
to be looking into to sort of 100
and i have to tell you in any of these
industries
it is so hard to create change and it's
going to take someone to do it
successfully and then everyone will
follow so let's get this done
yes yes miss barrymore has spoken
um well this story really spoke to me
ross and i'm very grateful to
be bringing it to the news today because
the new yorker magazine
put out an article email
is making us miserable now
it's about some scientific proof that
your email inbox can cause burnout and
anxiety they measured heart rate
variability and
measure for mental stress and found a
direct connection between checking your
email
and rising stress levels people are
trying to deal with it
france has actually passed labor laws to
limit after work emails
and companies like arianna huffington
and huffpo
are creating new features to fully
delete emails that get sent to you
while you're on vacation and i think it
is all about pushing this reevaluate
button because
when something that you empty and
conquer
just keeps filling up filling up filling
up you can
never escape the insurmountable
task of getting through your emails
this is going to have an effect on us
well and i know you
are now kicking at little house in the
prairie style you don't have an email
anymore
i got rid of it because if i heard one
more people say didn't you get my
email with a condescending look like i
was out of the loop
and dropping the ball in business or
with personal stuff
i went straight all to text and it has
improved my quality of life i don't know
what would cause me more anxiety like
taking a break from my email or not
having access to my email
i i think we live in this world where
like we have it just
is the way it is right and i i worry
that i would worry that i'd be missing
out on something i'd had fomo do you
have that at all not having access to
your email
no because now everybody's just texting
me
so i don't feel like i'm missing out but
i do think
this is the society we live in it's not
going anywhere but maybe we can
reevaluate
our expectations and approach to it find
that pretty little middle
okay girl maybe you convinced me just a
little bit to take an email chill pill
just a little bit
i'd also like you to help me find out
how to unsubscribe from j.crew because
they will not stop emailing me thank you
well look at you rossie if i was j crew
i'll be emailing you
you're flirting she's flirting